Welcome to the Atmospheric Lighting class
for Unreal Engine 5.6.
In this class, we'll explore the fundamentals
of working with and manipulating volumetric fog.
We'll also cover how to utilize God rays, fog cards,
and implement localized fog volumes
to add depth to your level.
We'll briefly cover the basics of using a post-processing
volume, as well as create a basic post-processing material
that can be added to a post-processing volume
or further artistic effect and control.
Finally, we'll wrap up the class
with a few hands-on examples of lighting an interior scene,
as well as briefly covering some concepts
when using megalights.
Let's get started.